[Music]
if you guys had a bet
hmm let's make this interesting if you
had to bid five
thousand dollars oh [ __ ] who have you
been on tyson
or roy jones jr oh i don't know i only
know
i don't know i don't know the other one
because i don't really follow this way
are they true
tyson's a good pick though they were
supposed to fight but they never fought
so who
is he junior yeah like who so we all
know mike tyson he's the
hangover guy right we all love that guy
how we know him yep that's how we know
him so he bit someone's
here to compare the two mike tyson is an
annihilator right
roy jones jr is this guy like he's the
one that does like the craziest like he
out classes boom he has like the
craziest
technical [ __ ] you've ever seen it makes
people look like never boxing did tyson
ever
wrestle the shark oh yeah whatever
happened with that box box
oh that was just shark week right yeah
wait was that really the thing yeah we
did a jk news on it but
but when we did it it was before the
event i think it was more of a joke
oh okay for shark week like discovery
doesn't shark week mean period time
no well yeah
wait what do you mean shark week i
thought that was cool it was like yeah
because there's blood in the water
is it an ant flow was that what they say
they say a lot of things
on the rag flow exactly you know the rag
sounds worse than saying i'm on my own
oh tyson is uh minus 350 favorite
of course and jones is uh that means you
win more if
he does win yeah and so jones is the
underdog so like for
for every dollar you get three hundred
fifty dollars so if he's
if he's negative what is he negative
three fifty now you know so you have to
bet if you want to bet you have to bet
maybe uh 350 dollars to win a hundred
dollars
oh that's how it works and then if it's
uh roy jones is what's his odds
plus 160. please plus 160 so you bet a
hundred dollars and you win 160 dollars
so usually what it is it's like vegas is
usually pretty spot-on so if that's the
odds that they set
that means it's a pretty good chance
that mike tyson is probably gonna win
and that's who i'm kind of leaning more
towards
tyson what makes you think tyson's gonna
win uh just the way
i think um roy jones fought a little
longer
you know and he had he got some like a
longer career
longer career later in his life who's
older
i think tyson by three years but they're
both over 50.
they're both over 50. yeah so i think
roy jones has a little more miles on him
not by much but it's i think enough
where he took a little more damage than
tyson did
do you think they both have ct though uh
i think yeah at this point they will
in the grand scheme of things i'm pretty
excited about what's happening because
like
a lot of these fights with like these
like legends when i was a kid i didn't
get a chance to watch them
so like i think this is supposed to be
like the first like kickoff
of seeing like legends resurface and
fight
so if you miss tyson in his heyday
here's a chance to see tyson
versus roy jones was also another like
and then it might start off like
holyfield versus someone else
and like all the people that you miss
growing up you get to see them
come on i think they're even bringing it
to not just boxing but like
seeing iverson play again you know i've
seen allen iverson play
i don't know scottie pippen or some [ __ ]
like it's does it make are you saying
like you didn't watch it as a kid
because like they
we were around when we didn't i didn't
order pay-per-view or
oh and you couldn't like re-watch it the
way yeah
you didn't really know like if you
missed the pay-per-view that was kind of
it unless they
had like replays and stuff like that
because i remember the holyfield fight
but i mean like i was
but that was like massive popular music
that was like
later on yeah yeah and then also now if
it wasn't
a covet this would be a spectator event
so now in the future
if this is successful you can watch
iverson play like in person like all the
greats that you wanted to see in person
true like you can see all those legends
does it take away though the fact that
they're
a little older and you're not really
seeing them
like there's like i mean roy jones known
for his speed and elusiveness
i mean and it's not gonna necessarily
translate is it gonna be the same
because you're gonna always wish like
man
after whatever happens next saturday
you're always going to be like man what
would have happened if both these guys
were
fought each other in their prime prime
because they were supposed to but it's
better
than going to a vegas impersonator show
yeah
it's like you're going to the biggest
britney spears experience
you know what i mean it's like it wasn't
her heyday but it's still britney's it's
still brilliant
and you still could pretend that it's
2002. that's a great analogy
that's actually really good yeah but but
it's going to be good enough where
it's like when you watch mike tyson
train you're like man this dude still
[ __ ] got it
when you see roy jones train you're like
this guy's still got it too
much vicious right now yeah i think i
think if you had to compare both of them
just like based off how they look
movement wise
i think you got to put the money on
tyson because the amount of violence
he's showing
it just looks like i think he's the
killer's back when you hear him talk
about it his
mentality is very like like i'm just
going to go out there and kill like he's
he's
he's thinking like that and that's the
tyson you want to hear you know he said
he was afraid to tap into that
and on his podcast and now he's tapping
into it exactly he's very competitive he
blamed it on his wife
because he said his wife told him to
lose like 15 pounds and he goes
you know what happens i think tyler's
weight and then he was like
he's like he started doing the treadmill
he's like just do 20 minutes a day
it goes 20 minutes turn into two hours
and then now i got a fight coming
20 minutes i didn't want to do it 20
minutes
on the treadmill every single day turned
into two hours a day turned into a full
fight camp
it was my [ __ ] wife fault you know
it's funny because like
during during this whole like build-up
you see mike tyson being like funny and
he's
you see him like you see him as like the
most vicious guy in his boxing career
right yeah but he's like the most
relaxed
ever yeah and then as the fighting
career stopped you see him like
be really funny he's doing roast season
if you see his podcast
yeah he's really good he does the
one-man show right so you see like oh
man he's finding different avenues which
is kind of hard for fighters he's a
goofball yeah exactly but then now you
see him turn
back into the [ __ ] murderer again
flip the switch again yeah
that's what i wonder if she's like [ __ ]
i just wanted him to lose that gun
probably she was like i missed the old
tyson
reignite the plane i fell in love with
did you see the recent one with him in
the pigeons no
yeah he was playing with some birds or
something oh
does he still have a tiger oh probably i
don't know
he has a ranch now like a wheat rancher
grandchildren
yeah oh well his whole podcast is him
smoking yeah it's called the hot box
yeah yeah that reminds me of in john
wick
um what's his name is on the roof with
all the birds
lawrence fishbox fishy fishburn
that's exactly that's the same thing but
yeah i think it's gonna be crazy and
then the uh
the under uh i think jake paul is
fighting too right yeah nate robinson
hey rob that's so weird who's nate
robinson he's a former
nba basketball player and then you have
like a youtuber it was just
i just didn't see the connection it's
just i guess they were talking [ __ ] like
like logan and
ksi i see the connection you know it's
like both like youtuber in the same
space it's like
we're this random nba guy and then
because i think he just left the nba
right
like a couple years ago so he i think
he's looking for an athletic pursuit and
he's like you know what i'm gonna make
some money if he can make a couple mill
off
fighting a guy like jake paul because i
think it's professional too right so
it's like six rounds for now well i
think it's
exhibition exhibition like even the
tyson roy jones stuff i think
like it was only two two minute rounds
got it but best believe these
[ __ ] are trying to knock
so scary dude as a fighter nick
uh why don't you ask me this fire dude
just [ __ ] that man
okay fine bart as a
how do you guys how would you guys
prepare against tyson
so obviously tyson's the favorite right
oh like if we have if you're in roy
jones you're shooting
yeah plan out your funeral i'm just
gonna say i'm yourself for your casket
if someone offered me like getting ct
and
broken ribs for sure what's your what's
the point
someone offered me like two million to
fight him and now
now my training camp i would it would
just be
all like dodging movements it just won't
get running around
my d is not even going to be close
enough to be able to
deal with his things three feet away at
all times
i will block away i will [ __ ] block
and get a concussion
yeah for real or maybe that's the way
out just
start off like this boom oh thank god
you cover up like this and then he
punches your body and you go ah
or you trip and fall on the way to the
right the tripping one yeah yeah
you just hold your knee you're like oh
man it's torn we just pretend to be
knocked out
like okay so he swings and you like you
pretend you got him he misses and he
just follows him
the possum technique dude or just jump
on him and bite his ear
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what i want to see is a holy
filled mike tyson maybe that piece
i know that's what i wanted how would
you train like to seriously fight him
what would you do
and say you say you're you're what's
like six foot right like
his height [ __ ] dude he looks like he's
too warm work on some
make sure my cardio is on point
what's up to be like more like just to
make sure you could last and because
you're going to be doing a lot of
running around you can do a lot of
circling you're going to be moving your
feet a lot so just a lot of footwork
[ __ ] dude i don't know man just tyson is
a [ __ ] man like
it's it's hard it's really hard to think
how do you prepare for a circle but i
feel like if somebody
if somebody could make this fight very
interesting it's a guy like roy jones
right but
his mobility and his movement is
probably going to be his way
of keeping him off because he is very
he's he's he has a very high boxing iq
he has really good finesse so i feel
like you know if anyone's going to do it
it can be roy jones i've been watching
mike tyson's uh younger fights like when
he's 13 and 14 and he was already a
killer yeah
like he would his 13 year old would beat
the [ __ ] out of me right now
bro him at 13 years old he's like oh
that's a grown ass [ __ ]
yeah really he's beating the [ __ ] he's
like 5
10 180 190 at 13. he's already been in
the fight have you seen those olympic
fights that he did sure
like i was like that doesn't even look
because you know like when they box an
olympics it looks
different from when they box
professionals usually guys don't get
like knocked down like yeah
and he was like knocking folks
it's not impossible but it's a lot
harder to like knock somebody out clean
like that there's this guy who
he fought um like right when the bell
right like you could see like
i think mike tyson got the wrong signal
so here you rush towards the center of
it and the rest like no no we haven't
started like he was like a raging bull
yeah so he blew the whistle and he came
out and he just started going crazy
and after about 30 seconds um the
opponent's
corner threw in the towel even though he
he didn't even get knocked down he was
just like
yeah he was just like this guy is too
violent i feel like mike tyson's
greatest weapon is his mentality yeah
because he he
lives like i think people don't really
understand
the reality of violence you know what i
mean like like he
and he he really embodies that he
personifies oh yeah
and to like the scariest degree
like this they have stories about how he
would get like kind of he would lose
sparring rounds
in the gym and he did training he would
go in the restroom and cry
and then come out and then just knock
the guy out oh [ __ ]
damn oh [ __ ] and to to like what are you
doing that don't worry about it
are you ready and he goes out and he
just beats the [ __ ] poor guy up you
know it's like
dude like i don't know i don't know what
you do against that like you better have
the same mentality you better be
ready to die if you fight that guy
there's no light sparring with him no
[ __ ] no dude let's take it easy
have you see him hitting pads and being
the [ __ ] pad guy i feel so yeah i
think of his elbows and i'm like oh
small
guy but did you see him interview eminem
on his podcast
no i didn't i sent you
i don't know are you a big eminem fan i
mean i'm a casual listener have you ever
met
me you've never met nikki have you nick
no i don't know anything
that's that's literally all that we know
about no really
he but when he's when eminem's getting
interviewed by mike tyson
he's like that's how i would be being
interviewed by eminem
like he's like was was it he was out of
his element
like he was just like oh my god it's
mike he's like my idol yeah
have you heard even joe rogan with mike
tyson so like mike tyson would say
something that's relatively funny
and then joe rogan's like that's not
supposed to be funny
[Laughter]
did y'all see the clip where tyson
basically punks this uh
rapper some rapper says something about
like uh like
there's something misogynistic or
something like against uh the lgbtq
community
community and then tyson just like puts
him in his place like you don't say [ __ ]
like that and this guy just crumbles
on the hot box i want to go for [ __ ]
[ __ ] my pants
damn you don't want to get on that guy's
bedside at all [ __ ] no
you want to be the nicest guy ever to
that guy if he was like but are you gay
i'm like yeah
i can't be you're like i can't you want
me i could do whatever you want what do
you want me to do you start crying just
tell me what do you want
do
you